from timcast.com
Alabama attorney general says the state
can prosecute people who facilitate
out-of-state abortions Alabama will not
permit abortionists to defy our laws and
enrich themselves by marketing
hopelessness to women
what did I say what did I say uh
a few months ago what did I say when Roe
v way was overturned my concern is that
you will end up in a situation where a
state that bans abortion
says or in encounters a conflict with
its citizens its residents and a state
that has Limitless abortion this is a
component of that escalation
we've talked about even recently
Colorado and Oklahoma where in Oklahoma
it's completely banned in Colorado it's
completely unrestricted what happens
when there's a couple there together
they have a they you know get pregnant
as it were and then after six months the
woman says I'm just really unhappy and
maybe Justified Maybe not maybe she's a
good person maybe she's cheating and she
said she wants to leave so she goes I
cannot
leave my husband unless I get rid of
this baby so at let's say seven or eight
months she flees in the middle of the
night to Colorado the man then says the
baby can survive and she's going to kill
it and he reports her to law enforcement
would Oklahoma take action now
apparently as of now no but this is what
Alabama has effectively begun the
process of and not even in the scenario
I described in the scenario where you
have like a guy saying please officer
law enforcement the baby is eight months
you know gestated and can survive
outside of the womb do not let her kill
it I will raise it on my own she can
leave I don't care and she says no I
don't care I'm gone I'm gonna go do it
there's a conflict in Alabama they're
just saying outright and they can do it
here's the story
Alabama has the power to prosecute
people who help women leave the state to
get an abortion according to a new
filing from the Attorney General Stephen
Steve Marshall Marshall has challenged a
lawsuit filed by two pro-abortion groups
the ACLU and the yellowhammer fund
against the state
the AG has asked the United States
district court for the Middle District
of Alabama to dismiss the lawsuit in his
motion to dismiss Marshall pointed out
the plaintiffs are not challenging the
constitutionality of the state's
Broadband abortions
instead they argue that because some
other states allows to abortion
plaintiffs have a right to conspire with
others in Alabama to try and have
abortions performed out of state
plaintiffs are mistaken Prosecuting
someone for forming a conspiracy in
Alabama is not an extra territorial
application of Alabama Law simply
because the planned conduct is to occur
Beyond state lines plaintiffs assert
that there is some difference because
the object of their conspiracy is legal
where it might occur but they don't
explain why that makes any
constitutional difference and it doesn't
the conspiracy is what is what is being
punished even if the conduct never
occurs that conduct is alabama-based and
within Alabama's power to prohibit now
to take that interpretation of the law
and apply it to uh the story the
scenario I was just proposing a woman in
the middle of the night decides she's
going to leave her husband and travel to
another state to get an abortion so that
she can eventually so she can leave him
the state then says
premeditated murder not the act itself
or getting you for what you planned in
our state and we have evidence that you
packed up prepared and sought to leave
to go get Aid in the killing of a human
life and did she talk to anyone before
did she in any way get advice from get
funding from Planned Parenthood for
instance what happens then in Alabama
let's let's go to Alabama right now the
question I ask you
under this ruling a woman goes to a
Planned Parenthood or an underground
Clinic look but Planned Parenthood is
probably the better example
and they say
she you know I want to get abortions we
can't do it in state but don't worry
here's the information you need to cross
the borders what happens then when the
AG gets a bunch of state troopers and
they surround a Planned Parenthood and
say you are all under arrest for
criminal conspiracy to commit abortion
I'm not saying that happens anytime soon
I honestly don't know my point is this
this is exactly what I was worried about
when I said with Roe v Wade the next
grain of sand in the Heap is going to be
law enforcement saying we've banned
abortion doesn't mean you can just go do
it somewhere else it's illegal
and then what happens when a person is a
fugitive from the law
getting an abortion in you know let's
say let's say Oklahoma Colorado is the
best example
Oklahoma petitions as everyone's talked
about with Trump and the marshals and
how it would go down Oklahoma petitions
the federal government says a fugitive
from law is currently in Colorado what
happens when Colorado says we're a
sanctuary for abortion and we will not
allow you to enforce this warrant you
got the makings of federal and
Interstate conflict yeah it is kind of
hard to understand what will happen I I
and I really don't know
um Alabama is an interesting study for a
couple reasons their abortion ban won't
uh that says women who obtain abortions
are not uh civilly or criminally liable
so they couldn't go after the woman
herself for going out of state but they
could go after like the yellowhammer
fund would pay for her travel let's say
or put up on a hotel so they could go
after anyone who's involved with that
organization the thing about Alabama to
note is that they have the human life
protection act which passed in 2019
which is also interesting because I
remember pre-row we were all talking
about this was sort of something a lot
of states were preparing for they were
updating their their abortion related
laws and with the human life protection
act act it uh defines the fetus as a
person legally and so in Alabama in
Alabama wow so again they were taking
steps to Define all of these things that
we debate and that are debated
nationally all the time because they
have a strong position on it and what
they want to do and like I said I think
it's hard to tell what would happen
every state has different laws so with
Alabama they wouldn't go after the woman
they would go after you know her friend
who drives her out of state maybe or or
the the uh the whoever pays for her
hotel or something what if she calls an
Uber and gets an Uber across state lines
do they arrest the Uber driver for
conspiracy even if they didn't know what
was going on I mean I think it would be
hard to
if like that did happen the rest of the
Uber driver and this is I'm not a lawyer
just playing one on this podcast
apparently uh but if the Uber driver
took someone out of state and then had
to go to court and was like I had no
idea I've never met this person I worked
for Uber it would be very hard to then
have a conviction in my opinion yeah how
could you ever prove conspiracy unless
you have a recorded conversation right
but if it's a couple and you know they
get pregnant accidentally and they go
out of uh out of state could if the
woman can't be uh criminally or
similarly similarly challenged could her
boyfriend who drove right but why why
can't she be why can't the pregnant
woman herself be criminally charged
that's just the Alabama Law and a lot of
states have something like that that a
judge will probably strike that down in
two seconds I mean the law is in effect
but maybe if it were to go to trial it
it if this gets tested you can't have a
scenario where a woman is sitting a
pregnant woman sits down next to her not
pregnant friend and the pregnant woman
says I want to abort this baby and the
friend says I can give you information
on a clinic and then they go ah but only
the woman who said she knew where the
clinic was Goes to Jail what the
initiator of the criminal conspiracy is
the pregnant woman herself now I'm not
saying women should be imprisoned for
seeking abortions not not at all I'm
actually the the more uh old school
Democrat pro-choice position I'm just
saying these two laws can't lead they
can't legally exist because you're going
to end up with someone challenging the
constitutionality of the criminal
conspiracy saying for what reason does
this one criminal act have an exception
where the person who initiates the
conspiracy is exempt from the law and
the judges have to say you can't do that
either the law applies to everybody or
nobody and if the law itself is
conspiracy and not abortion then the
pregnant woman must be charged with
conspiracy along with her friend but the
part that confuses me is that you're
saying that Alabama says that the fetus
is a human being so wouldn't it be
conspiracy to murder right it's a great
question
I mean I'm just trying to think of like
what's the actual charge personally I
don't think that there's enough here
I don't think there would be enough here
to prove the the conspiracy angle
um and on top of that is there much
enforcement for it like you can create
as many laws as you want is there going
to be much enforcement what does
enforcement look like right yeah I hate
this idea of arresting charging someone
for something they did outside of the
jurisdiction where it was illegal like
like weeds illegal in a state so you go
to a state where it's legal get high you
come back and they're like you're you're
a fugitive you just broke the law no I
didn't to clarify the AG is literally
saying
you are right and that the crime that's
being punished is the conspiracy to
commit an act the conspiracy to go smoke
so could you imagine if they try and
bust you on a conspiracy to go to a
state where something
that happens all the time that is
absolutely normal has been around for
hundreds of years if you are in a state
and you come together with buddies and
plot a crime in another state regardless
yeah if it's not a crime in the other
state you're plotting to go to another
state to gamble for instance I'm going
to Vegas to gamble is that conspiracy
now because it's illegal here that's why
the the uh return general statement of
like it's an Alabama Law and it's
illegal here and so that's what matters
is what I just I don't think that a
state can can decide what I can do in
another state that's insane it's
interesting for sure I mean the idea
what it makes me think of is like how
powerful all the states and how
important is state residency right like
if you claim residency in that state are
you supposed to obey those laws more
than anything else even when you're in
other states it's hard to say I will say
the I uh it would be interesting to
contrast this law to um the Idaho
abortion trafficking law so Idaho boards
Washington Washington is uh basically
very pro-abortion they've got all kinds
of times you can get you can you can
undergo an abortion but Idaho was much
more restrictive and so they had this
abortion trafficking law saying like if
in if I'm remembering the language
correctly it's specific to minors so if
a minor got pregnant and approached
Planned Parenthood or approach you know
know a friend's mom and so can you
please take me to Washington or wherever
Washington is just a key example to get
an abortion that adult could be uh
brought up on criminal charges because
they are uh if they don't tell the
miners parents so if they traffic a kid
out a pregnant teenager out of the state
to get an abortion and bring them back
that's against an Idaho law and the
governor of Washington was really
adamant that this was a terrible idea
and I asked him to take it down in you
make a really really good point about
the absurdity of a system based on pure
logic that would say if it's illegal
here you cannot plan to do it and that's
interesting because uh you mentioned
gambling Texas friends I just did a
quick cursory search largely illegal to
gamble in Texas it is a crime to place
Wagers on sporting events and you know
card games they have card houses for the
most part where you're allowed to do it
so it's it's questionable as to what
they determined to be gambling and I
guess the issue with poker in Texas is
that it's considered a skill game so it
doesn't fall in the same category but
the biggest casino I think in the
country is on the border just north of
Texas in Oklahoma and that's where
everyone drives to to go clearly you
have to talk with your friends and make
a plan to go drive up to the world's
biggest the country's biggest casino I
think maybe in one of the world's
biggest casinos and then I think it's
like a mile wide or something and then
uh commit crimes but what that really
tells us is our legal system is based on
culture and morality and not the written
letter of the law like I said a million
and one times it's illegal for women to
skydive on Sunday in Florida Google it
it's true they don't arrest anyone for
doing it right there's a ton of laws in
the books like you can't put an apple
pie on the windowsill on Tuesday because
it mattered back then but doesn't matter
now what the ques the question where
that's being asked right now is
as our culture breaks down
and law becomes the pure exercise of
power all that matters and I guess this
is actually a more black pilled
prescription or or um
perception perspective uh
when you're looking at the Joe Biggs
case and they're saying we're going to
give him 17 years because he's a
terrorist it's like were the terrorist
laws written to prevent a guy from
knocking down a four foot steel
barricade I don't I don't think so I
think they were written because we're
concerned about people blowing stuff up
but now it's being applied in a way that
they've decided they can morality be
damned you have the question of
skydiving in Florida no one's going to
enforce that because nobody left or
right would agree with the enforcement
of it no one in Texas agrees that you
should criminally prosecute someone for
conspiracy because they went to go
gamble a 45 minutes away in Oklahoma but
you're right they did conspire to commit
a crime in the future and it doesn't
matter where they do it so now the
question is when it comes to abortion
what will we see in terms of the
morality you are going to have AGS who
are pro-life
you hear Sheamus on the show when he
says abortion to be banned Nationwide
in in the moral view of a pro-life AG
abortion must be stopped in a state like
Alabama where they've banned it
they are going to use the law to
whatever
novel a claim they can to enforce a ban
an abortion it sounds like uh the
beginning of a pre- attempted pre-crime
where they're going to get you and
arrest you before you do the crime just
by thinking about it kind of thing I
don't like it but conspiracy is a
component of a criminal action but but I
think that the issue here is you're
right but it shows that that laws are
only enforced based on what our society
deems to be morally acceptable or
unacceptable no one would stand for
a couple of drinking buddies being like
we got to go up to Oklahoma on Sunday
and hit the blackjack tables and the
cops bust in the door but like you're
busted for conspiracy to gamble show me
your ID and no one would have thought
this be this possible either but the
issue of abortion is so morally
polarized that Oklahoma Colorado it's
banned there what happens if you get an
AG maybe they won't do it now but let's
let's give it a few years a new AG comes
in and he's thinking I want to win
political points because I want to run
for the governor governor's office I
want to run for the Senate the only way
I do it is if I if I cater to the wants
and desires or the people of my state
polls come out saying 67 80 percent of
Oklahomans want abortion banned and
people who get abortions to be
criminally charged he's going to go okay
if I am the AG of ending abortion I'm
going to win the governor's race in four
years so what does he do conspiracy to
commit abortion conspiracy to facilitate
abortion sends police to the Border
what I think we're seeing with the
polarization of politics in this country
is Democrats aren't going to stop
because their base demands it they want
to get elected they'll do whatever they
have to Republicans don't want to stop
because they want to get reelected and
they'll do what Their base says both
sides are demanding more and more uh
dissociative outcomes or dissociated
outcomes the right says no abortion the
left has unlimited abortion and now
their states have to escalate that
policy and procedure which means in
states with unrestricted abortion they
need to add more to it now they're gonna
have to you got Gavin Newsom I think
it's Newsom right here in the article
saying we will not cooperate with any
state that attempts to prosecute women
or doctors for receiving or providing
reproductive care now we're seeing the
escalation not only will these states
allow unlimited and unrestricted
abortion meaning a baby at nine months
they're also saying they will defy
federal law enforcement from trying to
stop a woman from traveling to their
state to get an abortion in defiance of
their own State's laws the right will
then have to escalate in kind like this
Alabama AG is outright saying we will
arrest you for conspiracy before you get
the chance there is going to be an
escalation Gavin Newsom will then say we
will use the powers of our government to
protect you if they try to persecute you
and then Alabama will say if the feds
won't do it we will send our law
enforcement or hire private contractors
to go and retrieve the criminal Fugitive
that's where you lose me I don't know
how States will have the um excuse me
have the resources to do this if we're
truly saying women start to flee the
state for abortions I don't think any
state has the Manpower it's called G4S
what is uh what is it security private
security company it's called Securitas
then you've got pmcs if it really comes
to the point basically mercenaries
Mercenaries
are you kidding epic mercenaries hunt
down women that's insane well look at
look at where we're at right now
states are either Banning it out right
and threatening to criminally prosecute
those involved like Alabama is or
they're doing the inverse saying that
there is no restriction at all on the on
when an abortion can take place and they
will defy the federal government from
intervening in a warrant it is so wild
that the states are so different like
that what I what do you think what's
your well I was actually thinking that I
don't know if this is even something
that could work
there could be something where we start
seeing temporary residencies for women
who are getting abortions right because
when I got an abortion I wasn't a
resident of Alabama I was a resident of
a neighboring state and I think that
could be the way that they kind of
subvert that conspiracy charge so these
women or anybody who tries to help them
because they became a resident and then
a month later they had the abortion so
you can't say we conspired in this other
state so I think that could be something
um and if States like California are
like the polar opposite well if they're
going to do that we're going to do this
then that could be something that you
see someone like Gavin Newsom saying
well you know what if they're saying
they can't have abortions we're gonna
not only we're gonna say they can do it
here but we're gonna put them in housing
here too so they don't get those charges
they're just good it's going to keep
escalating I don't know about making it
like some sort of police force or
anything like that or going private
security I think then the next step
would be
finding legal ways where they can get
away with it and I think temporary
housing would be one of those things
they can claim residency for a period of
time while they have an abortion and
then they can move but but it's all it's
it's all a great Super Chat someone
quoting steved saying it's a we're not a
nation of laws We're a nation of
political will from Jason
um Hutchinson and so it doesn't matter
what anyone does it doesn't matter what
legal loophole someone tries to create
it just matters that an aging into the
state says I don't care what you call it
right you got one judge telling the
proud boys you should have called an
election official or wrote to them you
got another another D.A saying because
you wrote to election officials and
asked them to help you you're going to
jail we're going to criminally charge
you yeah so it's just it's an issue of
willpower thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time